take a moment to read the following
how was that frustrating slow what were
those sentences about
they're actually a simulation of the
experience of dyslexia designed to make
you decode each word
those with dyslexia experience that
laborious pace every time they read
when most people think of dyslexia they
think of seeing letters and words
backwards like seeing b as d and vice
versa or they might think people with
dyslexia c saw as was
the truth is people with dyslexia see
things the same way as everyone else
dyslexia is caused by a phonological
processing problem
meaning people affected by it have
trouble not with seeing language but
with manipulating it
for example if you heard the word cat
and then someone asked you remove the c
what word would you have left
at
this can be difficult for those with
dyslexia given a word in isolation like
fantastic students with dyslexia need to
break the word into parts to read it fan
tas tick
time spent decoding makes it hard to
keep up with peers and gain sufficient
comprehension
spelling words phonetically like s-t-i-k
for stick and f-r-e-n-s for friends is
also common
these difficulties are more widespread
and varied than commonly imagined
dyslexia affects up to one in five
people it occurs on a continuum one
person might have mild dyslexia while
the next person has a profound case of
it
dyslexia also runs in families
it's common to see one family member who
has trouble spelling while another
family member has severe difficulty
decoding even one-syllable words like
catch
the continuum and distribution of
dyslexia suggest a broader principle to
bear in mind as we look at how the
brains of those with dyslexia process
language
neurodiversity is the idea that because
all our brains show differences in
structure and function
we shouldn't be so quick to label every
deviation from the norm as a
pathological disorder or dismiss people
living with these variations as
defective
people with neurobiological variations
like dyslexia including such creative
and inventive individuals as picasso
muhammad ali whoopi goldberg steven
spielberg and cher clearly have every
capacity to be brilliant and successful
in life
so here's the special way the brains of
those with dyslexia work
the brain is divided into two
hemispheres the left hemisphere is
generally in charge of language and
ultimately reading while the write
typically handles spatial activities
fmri studies have found that the brains
of those with dyslexia rely more on the
right hemisphere and frontal lobe than
the brains of those without it this
means when they read a word it takes a
longer trip through their brain and can
get delayed in the frontal lobe
because of this neurobiological glitch
they read with more difficulty
but those with dyslexia can physically
change their brain and improve their
reading
with an intensive multi-sensory
intervention that breaks the language
down and teaches the reader to decode
based on syllable types and spelling
rules the brains of those with dyslexia
begin using the left hemisphere more
efficiently while reading and their
reading improves
the intervention works because it
locates dyslexia appropriately as a
functional variation in the brain which
naturally shows all sorts of variations
from one person to another
neurodiversity emphasizes this spectrum
of brain function in all humans and
suggests that to better understand the
perspectives of those around us we
should try to not only see the world
through their eyes but understand it
through their brains
you